so for decades Americans feared that the
government would invade their privacy
and destroy their lives but it turns out
we didn't need the government for that
thanks to the spread of smartphones and
social media at any moment any day any
person can find themselves targeted
online by some sort of mob Greg Gutfeld
host the Greg Gutfeld show and co-host
the five I don't like him very much but
he did a very good job writing this
column on social media Redemption and he
recently joined Tucker and I taped it
this is all coming from what I thought
was a fantastic PC you wrote most news
com the headline remember when we
thought Big Brother government was Big
Brother Big Brother is us yes what does
that mean
we've happily embraced the role as our
nation's Hall monitors and our nation's
policemen and it's its it social media
triggers these two evolutionary
processes one to stand out so you go on
social media to gain attention so you
can get a partner it's it's ingrained in
your head and the other thing is a
survival mechanism group survival so
that means if you can find somebody and
eject them like a group like a sacrifice
you save yourself and this is something
you're not even aware you're doing but
we were on social media and you see
somebody screw up and you just join the
mob it's kind of it's almost like it's
an evolutionary process to save yourself
and it makes me think I think about like
all these people that if you have a bad
day if you just happen to have a bad day
and and somebody gets you on tape god
help you i and by article I was when I
wrote that I was thinking about with my
parents have survived back in the day
during social media as parents you know
we when you know you didn't have a lot
of stuff to entertain kids with there
were three TV channels yet lousy roller
skates you didn't wear helmets you're
always you know you're always your
parents who are so mad they get really
mad at their kids and spanked them
because they were worried it because you
almost killed yourself you know you're
always like worried about a lot of
course
yes but imagine if you just watch your
kids safe way now and you're in trouble
yeah totally right my wants my mom would
have been a meme so what's the way
for us I mean clearly social media abets
cruelty it's it's degrade of the society
it's made people lonelier actually as
you point out in your piece which is
ironic but true so what do you do
what's the redemption from this it's
it's kind of a I hate to use the word
collective but it takes a collective
action to decide that you're not going
to be part of the mob and it's just it's
just a moment a pause a moment of pause
when you are online and you see somebody
that you don't like it's really
important that it's somebody you don't
like screwing up let's say it's Joy
Behar or joy Reid or anybody named joy
and you do and they just say something
that like and everybody's on them it's
like what if you just decided not to
what if you decided not to demand that
they be fired what if you did now this
may not be reciprocated and I know it
won't be a Tucker if you are nice online
or I'm on nice online it's not like
Media Matters is gonna do the same to us
we know that no no but you're totally
right
no it begins with our self-restraint
right actually will you come back on for
Christmas to remind us of that because
that is the kind of thing we could start
2019 I'd remind myself of that attitude
I remind myself of this every time I
turn on that laptop and I go don't be a
jerk because once you get online you are
a lesser version of you you are never a
better version that is very smart greg
gutfeld thank you for that thank you